und zwar habe ich heute mich wirklich
aufgeregt so aufgeregt dass ich fast
geplatzt wenn immer im kopf so furchtbar
finde und zwar gibt es jetzt in hörsälen
sie sind wirklich keine scherze sind
keine fake news die erste uni sport
ungeimpfte studenten aus
ich habe das gelesen habe gedacht das
ist jetzt wirklich nicht deren ernst
also man hat ja schon die letzten wochen
und monate sachen world wo man gedacht
das kann ja nicht passieren einer
aufgeklärten gesellschaft wider unseren
jetzt ist es soweit die erste uni sperrt
die ungewissen studenten aus es ist die
friedrich alexander universität erlangen
nürnberg und die führt ab montag die 2g
regel ein und lässt ungeimpfte studenten
gar nicht mehr in die feuerwehr ein für
mich ist es ganz klar wir dürfen auf gar
keinen fall deutschen eine impfpflicht
haben aber wenn ich so was höre haben
bisher schon eine impfpflicht es aber
völlig konträr zur freiheit und ich weiß
dass dieser satz ist einen gewissen
pathos beinhaltet aber wer für die
impfpflicht ist ist gegen die freiheit